Hallo meine Lieben!
Ich bin hier mitten in der Türkei in Ordu an der Schwarzmeerküste
und jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich: "Kiki, was machst du hier?"
Und zwar werden wir - jetzt platzt die Bomsbe - unsere eigene Haselnusscreme auf den Markt bringen!
Und das wird nicht irgendeine Haselnusscreme, wir sind ja bewusst hier in Ordu.
Ordu - das wissen Viele, gerade die Türken unter uns -
ist bekannt für die aromatischen Haselnüsse.
Die Wetterbedingungen, das Klima: alles ist perfekt gegeben für eben beste und aromatischste Haselnüsse
und deswegen kam für uns auch nur Ordu infrage wenn wir so ein Produkt launchen möchten.
So und jetzt befinde ich mich jetzt hier schon direkt auf einem Haselnussfeld!
Und zwar ist das Haselnussfeld das von der Firma Gürsoy, das ist auch eine sehr bekannte Firma
und das ist für mich auch ein Privileg, dass der Herr Gürsoy höchstpersönlich gesagt hat:
"Kiki und Hamza, ihr dürft hierher fliegen, ihr dürft aufnehmen. Ihr dürft ganz transparent die Produktion von eurer eigenen Haselnusscreme zeigen!"
Und ich würd' sagen wir gehen jetzt einfach mal aufs Feld!
Kommt mit!
Die Haselnüsse wurden jetzt per Hand gepflückt und die werden gleich auch per Hand ausgebreitet
und 2 Tage lang in der Sonne getrocknet.
Und bis dahin ist auch alles noch menschliche Handarbeit.
Und dann erst wird die äußere Hülle, das Hüllblatt entfernt und das passiert dann maschinell
Und da können wir gleich auch filmen, das zeige ich euch nachher auch nochmal.
Die Haselnüsse werden hier aufgesaugt und von der Schale befreit.
und kommen dann über ganz kurze Wege in Säcken in die Fabrik.
Hier zeigt mir Herr Gürsoy die Kühllager der Fabrik und wenn man da drin steht,
dann überwältigt einen das wirklich, wie riesig die Hallen sind!
Und die Nüsse werden anschließend kalibriert - das heißt nach Größe sortiert -
und dann auf dem Band nochmal per Hand gefiltert, also gesäubert und noch einmal untersucht,
ob eventuelle Fremdkörper z.B. Schalenreste oder Steine enthalten sind.
Und im nächsten Schritt werden die Haselnüsse dann entweder als solche abgefüllt und für den Vertrieb vorbereitet
oder so wie bei uns zu Cremes weiterverarbeitet.
Und jetzt kommt hier der spannende Teil: ich bin gerade mitten im Labor und hier geschieht wirklich Magisches!
Hier werden Rezepturen ausprobiert. Ich darf mich einbringen, ich darf sagen:
"Das ist mir zu süß, das ist mir zu mild, hier ein bisschen mehr Haselnussaroma!"
Und das Interessante ist - das darf ich jetzt hier auch einfach so mal sagen -
Hier werden andere Haselnusscremes auch getestet und im Labor überprüft
und es kam tatsächlich raus, dass andere Anbieter dritt-, viert-, fünftklassige Haselnüsse anbieten.
Und bei uns ist wirklich die erstklassige Haselnuss gegeben,
doppelt geröstet und vom Aroma einfach traumhaft!
Ihr werdet es merken wenn ihr dann auch endlich probieren dürft!
Und jetzt sitze ich hier, habe einiges an Cremes probiert
und ich würde sagen wir haben die perfekte Rezeptur gefunden!
Die Kiki Haselnusscreme ist geboren, sie ist köstlich!
Ich werde euch versichern, dass ihr sie lieben werdet!
Und was mir einfach wichtig war: Es ist kein einfacher Brotaufstrich!
Klar, das könnt ihr auch gerne machen aber insbesondere könnte ihr meine Haselnusscreme jetzt
für Tortenfüllungen, für Cremes, für Desserts verwenden.
Und ich werde euch natürlich auch fleißig mit Rezepten beliefern
und wir sehen uns dann gleich nochmal wieder!
So, das Meeting ist beendet!
Wir haben hier einiges an Cremes probieren dürfen
und ich habe jetzt die für mich perfekte Formel gefunden und ich würde mal sagen:
Kikis Haselnusscreme ist offiziell geboren!
Und ich danke dem ganzen Team, dass wir hier so fleißig probieren durften
und auch das Privileg haben, hier die eigene Haselnusscreme entwickeln zu dürfen.
Vielen Dank!
So, endlich ist es soweit: Die Haselnusscreme ist da Leute!
Dieses Projekt hat sich wirklich 1 Jahr gezogen
aber gute Projekte brauchen eben auch eine Weile damit sie perfekt werden!
Also vom Geschmack her: große, ganz ganz große Liebe!
Also wenn ihr probiert, dann schmeckt ihr die Liebe raus!
Das hat der Hamza so schön gesagt und das kann ich hier auch nur wiederholen.
Ihr schmeckt die Liebe raus, ihr schmeckt die erstklassigen Haselnüsse raus
und dass sie doppelt geröstet sind!
Und was auch viel ausmacht - und das unterscheidet finde ich meine Haselnusscreme von herkömmlichen Cremes -
natürlich nicht nur die extrem hochwertigen Zutaten sondern auch: Wie verhält sich die Creme beim Backen?
Also ihr könnt sie so wie hier aufs Brot schmieren, das mache ich die letzten Wochen jeden Morgen
und auch als Abendbrot teilweise!
Ihr könnt aber auch damit backen!
Zum Beispiel könnt ihr sie in Cremes verarbeiten, ohne dass die Creme euch zu flüssig wird.
Ihr könnt sie als Guss benutzen.
Das heißt: Wie verhält sich die Creme wenn ihr sie im Wasserbad oder in der Mikrowelle erwärmt?
Und da habe ich wirklich die perfekte Konsistenz rausbekommen
und die Formel ist wie patentiert.
Also die gibt es wirklich nur bei uns und nirgendwo anders auf der Welt und das macht sie so besonders!
Und das Tolle ist: Hier ist weder Palmöl drin, noch Konservierungsstoffe,
Farbstoffe, keine Gentechnik - also ein total cleanes Produkt!
Hier ist nichts in der Zutatenliste, was ihr nicht aussprechen könnt und das war mir besonder wichtig.
Ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim Probieren!
Eine kleine Warnung habe ich: 100%-ig werdet ihr süchtig!
Das garantiere ich euch, da habt ihr die Kiki Garantie!
Die Suchtgefahr ist auf jeden Fall groß!
Ich werd euch natürlich den Link zu meinem Onlineshop unten in die Videobeschreibung einfügen
und ansonsten hoffe ich auf eure Kommentare, schreibt mir gerne.
Und falls ihr gut aufgepasst habt, dann habt ihr gesehen, dass eine Schokovariante auch schon in Planung ist!
Jetzt hab ich's...
jetzt hab ich's verraten!
Durfte ich das nicht verraten?
(Hamza: Nein, ist in Ordnung!)
Okay, eine Schokovariante ist auch in Planung! Die Rezeptur steht und das Projekt wird jetzt in Angriff genommen.
Also ihr merkt wir sind einfach hungrig nach neuen Projekten und das ist wirklich so.. *seufzt*
Das ist einfach so unser Herz, das da drin steckt!
Also ich wünsche euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag
und bis zum nächsten Mal auf meinem Kanal!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!
Und der Hamza!